le premier spectacle à faible
consommation énergétique
j'ai vraiment vu un documentaire à la
télévision sur le tilapia
tout le monde sait ce que c'est que la
télévision c'est pas un pression d'eau
de mer fait pas un poisson d'eau douce
c'est ce qu'on appelle la boisson dossal
voilà c'est assez compliqué comme ça de
l'art gamers déjà parce qu'il faut déjà
avoir 9
je voudrais que jour le verguet j'ai
l'impression c'était le nouvel an j'aime
bien que les invités au restaurant
j'appelle toute sa famille juste avant
le dessert je me suis levé j'ai dû me
coûter si je vous ai réunis c'est parce
que tu vas demander d'emménager avec toi
et je veux que tout le monde sache ici
qu il en est hors de question donc je
crois qu'il est grand temps de s'arrêter
là champagne
[Musique]
politique la totalité de l'argent
récolté sera reversé dans mon verre sous
la forme de vin bio 100 smart